نعم لا تزال محاولات السلطات التركيه لجر
هذه السفينه بعيدا عن المكان الذي جنحت
الي نحن كما تشاهدون الان في الخلفيه وعلى
الشاشه مباشره هذه هي السفينه التي جنحت
وكانت قادمه من اوكرانيا هناك ثلاث سفن او
ثلاث قاطرات للشحن تحاول جر السفينه
ومحاوله تعويم السفينه ومن ثم ابعادها عن
هذا المكان الذي جنحت اليه تقريبا ليس
قريبا حركه الملاحه توقفت تماما
على جانبي او في الاتجاهين في مضيق
البوسفور سواء من البحر الاسود او من بحر
جاءت توقفت الحركه تماما قبل قليل وادي
اسطنبول تحدث عن هذا الموضوع وقال ان
السفينه حدثت فيها عطل في موجه القياده
لذلك همم
لذلك جنحت وتحاول السلطات جاهده ل همم
لابعادها عن هذا المكان بحسب وادي اسطنبول
ان في السفينه ليست ايه محمله همم او ما
رشحا او ما فهمناه من بيان والاسطنبول هذه
السفينه ليست محمله بمشتقات نفطيه اموال
نفطيه لذلك كما ذكرت في همم قبل قليل في
النشره السابقه ربما البعض يرجح ان هذه
السفينه ربما تكون محمله بالحبوب لكن حتى
الان لا توجد معلومات اكيده حول حموضه هذه
السفينه السلطات لم تعلن همم السفينه
بالضبط جنحت في الساعه السابعه والنصف همم
تم جروح السفينه همم الى شاطئ بيكوز همم
عند مرورها من مضيق الوصفور من البحر
الاسود وهمم كانت متجهه الى بحر ايجه
قادمه اوكرانيا في تمام الساعه السابعه
والنصف بها التوقيت المحلي الرابعه والنصف
فجرا بتوقيت جرينتش همم جناحات هذه
السفينه ومنذ ذلك الحين اين تحدث تقريبا
عن همم اربعه ساعات همم ما زالت المحاولات
مستمره من قبل السلطات التركيه لحل هذه
المشكله